i assume that's what he said
he's talking a dot's a good thing it is
what he's got well he's dot in the eye
and just every time it's bam oh right
perfect you put the eye right in the
braces throwing dots just it hits me
wherever i want i mean i don't
that's a new one to me but i'm guessing
that's what he means by that but i mean
like the dot he threw to hill against
the bills that that he'll drop that may
not be a good thing because that was a
dot he dropped it that's okay he'd still
it was a dot and he liked it i mean
he'll like it he'll want more of those
throws he's just gonna hope he'll catch
it next time but yeah so that's that's a
new one and
i don't know mike i mean
hey i'll i'll like lean on something you
said all year long and that's where i
like think the game is very interesting
because of course i think the bucks can
win
but
you've always talked about and this is
your spaghetti and meatballs gut here
but when the chiefs when you get their
full attention
and we saw like the bills kind of had
their full attention and you went oh
well it was really strong all the way
through all phases of the game really
other than you know their early miscue
on the the punt return
uh i i just
i just worry that happens this week that
they're that that they're that special
hey you know basically a 15 and one
football team yeah 14 and two because
they didn't play at the end of the year
it's mahomes
i think the brady thing would have his
extra attention this week to make sure
he's throwing lots of dots and things
like that
i just wonder if we're gonna see like
the the ultimate chiefs this week that's
where
you know the team that we've seen where
we go oh they're gonna blow this team
out and then they mess up a play here
and there and they don't bulld them out
i just wonder if now super bowl
you know if they can maybe capitalize on
all those momentum things and actually
put a stranglehold on a team like for
real for the first time all year
well
but it doesn't have to be the playoffs
to get the chief's full attention no it
doesn't part of me wonders
how much of week 12 when they ran up the
17 nothing lead was a product of getting
the chief's full attention right now it
got closer in the second half
it did
it and that was not your typical chiefs
they let their foot off the gas the
buccaneers adjusted but we may have
already seen full focused chiefs against
the buccaneers because part of me thinks
oh god if they did that to them in the
regular season what are they going to do
to him in the super bowl but it's just i
think that that brady mahomes thing is
always going to be a factor when those
two cross paths especially now that
they're in different conferences and
mahomes may have entered that game
against brady thinking quite justifiably
this is the last time i'm ever going to
play this guy because four years from
now he's gonna be gone so this is it
this is my last chance to beat brady
let's go beat brady so they're
the more i'm talking myself into this i
think we saw full focus chiefs week 12
right that would have been a game from a
holmes to to to distinguish himself from
the other games where it's just random
team that is frothing at the mouth to
beat the chiefs and say hey we beat the
best team in football so that that part
of it is very uh that it's concerning to
me
yeah as you as you'll see when we make
our picks that's my big caveat i get you
that that the chiefs have the capacity
to blow any team off the field right if
they could we said this time and again
if they could ever put that offense
especially if we could ever put full
four full quarters together of the
efficiency that we see
from time to time they could sustain
that for 60 minutes they would blow out
everyone that they faced yeah no that's
where you know and again like you're
kind of just laid out it was very close
to being that
it was 17 nothing it was first in goal
in the eight yard line you know mahomes
kind of lost sight of shaq barrett and
got hit and fumbled i mean it's rare you
don't really ever see that it was like
almost shocking watching it back but so
there's that moment where you're going
hey listen
the emotions of the game are high
everything's intense here and kansas
city's having their way in every moment
of the football game at that point and
that's what does scare me a little bit
there's no doubt about that you know
games 27 10 we've talked about that too
mrs mccole hardman on the throw where he
hits it 999 times out of a thousand it's
a wide open walk-in 80-yard touchdown
and they miss it so those are the things
that do scare me too mike i'm with you
it just seems like every year or there's
so many times during the year
you know the chiefs do stuff like that
we're we're about to blow you out and
it's over and we fumble or you know we
drop a pass like we saw in the dolphins
game there's a few other games
throughout the year where you go they're
going to blow them out and then they let
a team hang around and that's where it's
going to be fun to watch on sunday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports